Transcriber: Pauline Romanos
المدقّق: Mujtaba Abdelwhab
مرحباً، وأهلا وسهلا بكم
يشرفني و يسعدني ان اكون معكم اليوم
لمشاركتكم تجربتي في ثلاث مجالات
الذين هم الفن
والعمارة والفنون، برأيي أن هذه الثلاث
مجالات يمكن أن يشكلوا أجمل لوحة فنية
تتضمن طُرُز معمارية وعناصر زخرفية
تتضمن تأريخ لحقبة معينة من الزمن،
وتتضمن أيضًا أساليب فنية مرتبطة بزمن معين،
وترتبط أيضًا بالفنان نفسه، بطبيعته، وحياته
وشخصيته، وممكن لهذه اللوحة أن
تشكّل رسالة تاريخ وطن.
عندما تخرجت من المدرسة وكنت سأدخل
الجامعة، كانت تلك التخصصات الثلاث
هدفي في الدراسة،
وبترتيب الأهمية، الهندسة المعمارية
والفنون التشكيلية والآثار،
وفعلاً، درست الهندسة
لكن استمرشغفي بالفن والآثار،
وظلّت دراستهم تراودني.
وأثناء الدراسة تابعت الرسم وكنت أرسم
منذ الصغر،
وظللت أرسم ورسمت عدة لوحات مختلفة،
بألوان الرصاص، وكانت لوحات
بسيطة للطبيعة والطيور.
بعد تخرجي من الجامعة اشتغلت
في التخطيط العمراني،
استمريت في شغفي بالفن، ورسمت عدة
لوحات للطبيعة بالألوان المائية،
بعد ذلك كان لي حياتي الخاصة
ومسؤوليات جديدة.
وسكنت خارج البلد، ولكن استمر شغفي بالفن،
لكن هذه الفترة كانت مختلفة، لأن شغفي
بالفن والرسم امتزج مع الحنين للوطن،
ورسمت أول رسمة لي، وهي رسمة عن القدس
التي هي لوحة قبة الصخرة المشرفة.
هذه اللوحة التي اشتركت فيها بعدة معارض
ونلت فيها عدة جوائز،
من ضمنها جائزة للشيخة جواهر القاسمي،
وكان المعرض في مدينة الشارقة
مع عدة فنانين تشكيليين
من جنسيات مختلفة،
في عام 2003.
هذه اللوحة وهذه الجائزة وهذا الإنجاز
في وقتها هو
الذي أعطاني الدافع والحافز للاستمرار
وتطوير الذات.
أكملت شغفي بالفن ورسمت عدة لوحات
مختلفة عن مواضيع مختلفة
وبأساليب مختلفة،
أكثر هذه اللوحات كانت عن مدينة القدس.
وفي وقتها كان تحدّي أن اطوّر نفسي
وصقل الموهبة، لأن دراستي
لم تكن الفنون التشكيلية
وبرجوعي إلى القدس، قرّرت
بعد 12 عامًا،
أن أدرس الآثار
وعندها درست الماجستير وحصلت على تقدير
جيد جدًا في الآثار.
وكانت رسالتي عن الأعمال المعمارية
للأمير تنكز الناصري في مدينة القدس،
دراسة بحثية أثرية ومعمارية وفنية .
وهذا الذي زاد شغفي بالفن لرسم المعالم
الأثرية لمدينة القدس.
وبهذه الفترة تمكّنت
من جمع الثلاث مواضيع  في لوحاتي
وهم الذين سعيت لهم منذ البداية.
ألا وهم الهندسة المعمارية والفنون
التشكيلية والآثار.
وقدّمت أول معرض لي في مدينة القدس،
والذي أتاح لي المجال أن أتعرف على زملائي
الفنانين التشكيليين
وأن أعمل معهم معارض مشتركة.
أضاف تواجدي في القدس في هذه الفترة
نكهة مختلفة للوحاتي
نكهة مقدسية بامتياز.
فأنا متواجدة في القدس ولوحاتي عن القدس
وارسم عن القدس. وهكذا أستطيع إن أحقق
رسالتي،
التي تحمل رسالة تاريخ وطن .
لوحاتي التي أرسمها حاليًا
هي دمج ومزيج
بين الفنون من ناحية إحدى المدارس الفنية،
والتي هي المدرسة الواقعية والأشكال
والألوان.
وبين العمارة من خلال
رسم المعالم والصروح المعمارية
والأشكال والواجهات والمنظور
والظلال والزوايا ، وبين الآثار من
خلال تاريخ هذه الأبنية .
وجمع المعلومات عنها وتوثيقها
ونشر الوعي
بأهميتها كمعالم أثرية موجودة
في مدينة القدس للحفاظ عليها
وللتمسك بالجذور والهوية .
خاصة أن العديد من هذه العمائر هي
عرضة للتهميش والتخريب وطمس المعالم .
وبما أن هذه الأبنية هي أبنية حية فهي ليست
مجرد حجارة ، هي أبنية تنبض بالحياة
فكان هناك إصرار على رسمها بدقة .
حتى أقدر أبني جسور تواصل بين المشاهد
وبين اللوحة
، وحتى لإظهار مدى البراعة
التي تحلى بها الفنان المعماري
في الأزمنة السابقة.
فهذه الأبنية تحدثنا عن تاريخها وعن موقعها
وعن طبيعتها وعن طرزها وعلاقتها بالأبنية
المجاورة لها و التي شكلت النسيج الحضري
للمدينة التي نحن نعيش فيها .
وبالحديث عن المرأة فالمرأة هي جزء من
المجتمع
والمرأة الفلسطينية خاصة، هي جزء
من المجتمع الفلسطيني ، وهي جزء فعال
وفي مجال الفنون التشكيلية أيضاً .
فهي لم تعد مجرد رمز داخل إطار
اللوحة ، لكن تطور حضورها
ليصبح لها حضور خارج إطار اللوحة ،
وأصبحت هي المبدعة
التي تحيك لوحتها من طموحاتها
ومن أهمية دورها في الحياة
وأصبح لها رؤية خاصة
بها تعنيها وتثبت طموحاتها
وآمالها دون أن تنفصل عن دورها بالطبيعة
كامرأة وصديقة و زوجة وأم ،
وأصبح حضورها في داخل أو خارج إطار اللوحة
يجمع بين الشفافية والصبر والحنان والدفء ،
بالإضافة إلى قضايا المجتمع وقضايا الوطن .
وأنا بدوري في هذا المجال
كنت قادرة على تحقيق ولو جزء بسيط
من نمط فني خاص بي
له مكانته في مجال الحركة الفنية
، وكان هذا من خلال المثابرة
والسعي إلى الأفضل بجهد
رغم كل التناقضات
والتحديات والصعوبات التي نعيشها
لأن رسم معالم القدس يتضمن
مسؤولية وتحدي
لإنجاز عمل فني ملهم يليق بمكانة القدس .
ومع دعم عائلتي ومشاركتي بمعارض مختلفة
والجوائز التي نلتها، من ضمنها جائزة أفضل
فنانة تشكيلية جسدت القدس في لوحاتها لعام
والتي قدمت من منتدى المثقفين المقدسين.
هذا الذي أعطاني
الدعم والحافز للاستمرار .
والدعم النفسي
فكان للفن واللوحة الأثر في حياتي
وحيّزي الخاص الذي
أعيش فيه بضع ساعات
بين الألوان والريشة
وبين الأبعاد الأربعة للوحة
وبعدها الخامس الذي هو البعد الزمني ،
وفي النهاية رسالتي هي
أن كل شخص فينا لديه
طموحات وآمال
مهما كانت صغيرة أو كبيرة ،
المهم، أن يسعى إلى تحقيقها حتى لو أخذت منه
فترة طويلة من الزمن
، والأهم من هذا كله
أن نقوم بها بحب وشغف وإخلاص
حتى نستطيع إيصال فكرتنا للآخرين
، وأن نبني ثقة بأنفسنا
أننا قادرين على تحقيق آمالنا
أو جزء بسيط منها ، فالحياة هي مدرسة كبيرة
كل يوم فيها درس جديد ولا يمكن أن تتوقف
عند نجاح معين أو فشل معين. كل يوم هناك
تجربة جديدة .
وشكرا لحضورك واستماعكم.
شكرا .